Not all lies are alike. Some people lie, but...
their lies are not caused by a serious
mental illness. Constantly, psychopath lie
habitually, and their vice is a part of a
personality disorder that makes them
cold hearted and have no conscience.
How can you tell if the liar you know it's a...
psychopath? Here are some telltale signs one...
psychopaths lie extremely frequently many...
people tell a white lie once in awhile to...
spare someone's feelings. Psychopath lie...
pathologically about anything and
everything deception is an integral part
of their disorder... (Two) Psychopaths lies
are driven by multiple motives. Ruthless...
powerful, dictators like Stalin and
Hitler were Psychopaths... they lie and
means a manipulation to exercise dominance...
over others. These individuals also lie...
to cover up their misdeeds in illegal...
activities. Characteristically, they tell...
the ultimate lie "I love you..."
Psychopaths have a convincing manner
lying seems to be as effortless as
breathing for a psychopath since they
lack empathy they can lie while looking
people in the eye and be very convincing;
because they're skilled actors and don't...
feel shame they can give the impression
of being guiltless. (4) Psychopaths rely
on people sympathies, they play upon the
natural tendency of people to want to
help those in need.
It's common for them to fake injuries or
ailments. Their ease and skill in the art of  deceit...
opens the doors for many exploitation
opportunities
(five) A psychopath's truth is momentary; as
their feelings are shallow the truth
they tell are only momentary varities for
example, they may declare their love for
girlfriend in the heat of passion, but an
hour later be in hot pursuit of another
woman...
the focus is always on the next
temporary pleasure...
(six) Psychopath leave behind trophies of their lies
The cruelty of psychopaths leads them to
leave behind tangible proof of their
deceit, known as trophies
it's a way of flaunting their lies for
example, if they're having an affair
they might leave a trinket from their
girlfriend a place where they know it
will be discovered by their wife.
This is a game of catch me if you can...
this could also be spending time with
one woman you are texting another living
on the edge is a thrill for them...
(seven) Psychopaths have their own
language, common phrases and statements
have a different meaning for psychopaths.
For example, "you're my one and only" might
mean, "You're one of a long line of woman
who has succumbed to my charm."
Likewise, "Trust me..." might translate into
"What a dope!"
(eight) Psychopaths are masters of denial
and minimization. They're good with the
Denial's and minimization when their lies
are discovered. If confronted with their
deceit they quickly accuse the victim
of imagining things or exaggerating.
Thus, their denials compound the lie...
Nine, psychopaths are addicted to deception
people afflicted with this disorder have
no desire to stop lying. The biggest
emotional high comes from deceiving a
woman who trust them. Regardless of how
much trouble they get into because of
their lies, they lack more incentive to
improve their behavior
Ten, psychopathic liars have certain personality traits...
Their habitual lies are part of a
personality profile that is indicated
of  their illness in addition to the
aforementioned manipulative tendency.
Desire to dominate, and lack empathy now. They're...
also bored, irresponsible, narcissistic...
remorseless, and charming now that you
know ten ways to spot a psychopathic
liar
Do you think you've ever encountered one...
in your life?
How did you deal with it? Feel free to
tell us in the comments below. If you
enjoyed this video, don't forget to check
out our website and other social media
and don't forget to subscribe. Thanks for
watching and have a wonderful day